[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler de cette
longue allocution riche en annonces
maxime cvo docteur en droit public éric
bouchard médecin généraliste président
honoraire du syndicat des médecins
libéraux dans les alpes-maritimes et
enfin alexis poulain éditorialistes
bonsoir à tous les trois merci messieurs
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
on va essayer de décortiquer un une par
une quasiment ces annonces avec
notamment luc allégé qui est en direct
sur place qui a suivi cette allocution
mais avant peut-être une petite première
impression de ces mesures maxime
thiébaut beaucoup d'annoncés
effectivement qui n'ont pas forcément
faire plaisir à tous les français ce
soir on imagine oui parce qu'on fait et
même si elle n'est pas de droit la
vaccination de viabilisation d'eau fait
il pourrait plus prendre le train vous
ne pourrez plus à le restaurant vous ne
pourrez plus on fait de vivre la vie est
terminée si vous n'êtes pas vacciné
donc il faut bien comprendre ici que
malgré tout la logorrhée qu'on a pu
entendre
nous sommes classés une vaccination
obligatoire des français qui pose
beaucoup de questions sur le plan de
l'éthique notamment parce que nous
sommes ici aussi dans une dans une
situation sanitaire qui fait la ned 6
nations reste sous une autorisation en
d'autorisation de comment de vaccination
qui est conditionnel pardon il ya
beaucoup de français qui utilisent sont
inquiets quant aux conséquences sur le
long terme des différents vaccins qui ne
voulaient pas particulièrement dans ce
lac signer parce qu'il faisait dans la
balance
en langage risque et cette balance il en
revenait plutôt positif quant à ne pas
se faire vacciner et ils sont malgré
tout obligé en pratiquement la corde au
cou que d'aller se faire vacciner je
pense notamment aux jeunes
quand on regarde en réalité les chiffres
faut arrêter de dire n'importe quoi mais
quand on regarde les chiffres si les
personnes vulnérables et les personnes
âgées sont vaccinés
les taux de spa ti hospitalisation dans
les pays où les variants delta est
arrivé dont augmenter à partir du moment
les personnes qui étaient celles qui
saturaient les hôpitaux italiens les
personnes qui ont des comorbidités et
les personnes âgées sont vaccinés vous
n'avez plus de saturation d'hôpitaux
et donc le fait de vacciner les plus
jeunes les personnes qui sont ou les
personnes qui sont pas les premiers
concernés par la mortalité de ce virus
revient finalement simplement à leurs
obligés de l'acsi nation qui n'est pas
en réalité nécessaire pour hélas apporte
une véritable atteinte à la liberté
vaccinale et on verra ce que dira le
conseil constitutionnel suite au vote de
la loi qui doit intervenir fin juillet
mais je pense que tout cela était
préparée d'avancé que le parlement sera
suivie on va écouter et d'exposants dans
quelques instants que je sens déjà
bouillir ce je vois la fumée au dessus
de votre tête alexis mais je vais
d'abord donner la parole aux médecins
est ce que vous êtes un un médecin
plutôt satisfait ce soir on entend voilà
les arguments du juriste un de l'homme
de droit on va entendre celui
d'éditorialistes en quelques instants
mais vous le médecin c'était nécessaire
parce que on va aller dans les détails
mais c'est vrai que qu'on rend quasiment
une vaccination obligatoire en tout cas
si on veut mener une vie un tantinet
dans normal un bien deux choses d'abord
concernant les soignants il est évident
que c'est quand même une très bonne
nouvelle pour les patients en
particulier
c'est vrai qu'on aime nous déjà tant que
soignant des obligations dans les
médecins d éviter une technicienne sont
obligatoires
comme pour l'hépatite et donc je dirais
que c'est un prince qui amène
normalement et ependes aurait on devrait
même pas se poser la question de savoir
si en tant que soignant votre vaccinaux
non ce qui est hallucinant est
vraisemblable c'est que encore 40% des
soignants dans les maisons dans les
ehpad ne sont pas ratifié donc je dirais
qu'il ya quand même un problème je
rappelle qu'on a une liberté comme ils
disaient que nous les interlocuteurs
d'armé ont fini aussi les obligations
n'at on a des choses à faire on vit pas
je dirais sommes dans son coin
voilà il ya plus de société il ya
torrent qui existe parce qu'elle a on
peut aussi rouler tous à 250 euros 100
km sur autoroute s'occuper des voisins
mais on voit une faute résonna je trouve
que concernant la partie vaccination des
soignants c'est très bien vous avez le
droit de ne pas d'accord avec moi mais
je ne sais pas du tout d'accord avec
vous et je vous rappelle que vous avez
dit non
non c'est une maladie qui tue des
personnes dans les rues d'ibb les règles
six nations c'est une démence et
subjective a sorti sa chaussure londres
absolument pas si je vais juste qu'ils
sont complètement faux dans le détail de
ces mesures on voudrait on va entendre
vos arguments en détail dans quelques
instants puisqu'on ils sont très
intéressants on va quand même rapidement
passer par alexis poulet avant de
retrouver le cas légers alexis votre
réaction ce soir
pour moi c'est ce soir un discours
extrêmement inquiétant presque délirant
dangereux et mal macron a prouvé qu'il
était le président de la violence dans
la façon qu'il a eue de gérer les
manifestations des mouvements de gilet
jaune avec une violence d'état
aujourd'hui la violence va plus loin
puisque c'est une obligation de vacciner
de se vacciner alors même que cette
obligation ne devait pas entrer dans les
textes puisque ce vaccin est en phase
test même si bien sûr on ne parle plus
d'une phase test du produit une phase
test de l'efficacité de ce produit est
d'ailleurs l'efficacité pose question
puisque une troisième dose sera offerte
aux vacciner de la première heure
puisque visiblement ce vaccin ne suffit
pas il va falloir aller plus loin et
puis comme les variants vont arriver
encore et encore sans doute on aura des
doses trimestrielle voire mensuelle
puisque maintenant sur les copies de
l'ont apparemment des doses mensuel
ferait des miracles
alors il ya une vraie question
aujourd'hui est le maquereau demande aux
soignants d'être vaccinés les premiers
parce qu'ils sont au contact des
populations
il n'a dit aucun mot sur les policiers
qui sont également des métiers de
contact qui vont être eux qui vont
regarder les douaniers policiers qui
vont regarder si les passes sanitaires
sont efficaces dans les bars il est pas
sanitaires sont efficaces ah oui dans
les aéroports etc
bon pourquoi les policiers n'ont pas
obligation vaccinale est pourquoi
finalement on va pousser toutes les
classes de population sauf ceux là qui
vont organiser la répression
aujourd'hui ce qui se met en place avec
cette politique sanitaire c'est une
politique de répression une politique de
contrôle
c'est pas du tout politique sanitaire le
locaux vides et je suis d'accord avec
maxime thibeault c'est un virus qui tue
bien sûr c'est un virus dangereux
évidemment c'est un virus qu'on ne
connaît pas on ne sait toujours pas d'où
il vient comment il s'est créé et
qu'elles vont
être ces évolutions et bien sûr le
risque c'est qu'il évolue vers quelque
chose de plus grave
aujourd'hui nous avons des vaccins
efficace certes mais pas assez quand on
vaccine sur les onze vaccin obligatoire
des nouveau-nés évidemment qu'on le fait
puisqu'on a le recul suffisant et que
sans ça la polio reviendrai et d'autres
maladies encore plus grave donc oui les
vaccins sont une avancée formidable mais
ce produit de pfizer et ça me fait rire
parce qu'aujourd'hui on parle de vaccins
autorisés par l'autorité européenne du
médicament donc on parle de vaccins
américains allemands
mais quand il est question du vaccin
russe pour migrer du vaccin chinois
alors là il ya plus personne et puis on
dit finalement à une attendait les
français préparent à vaccin c'est pour
plus tard on verra on a pris beaucoup de
retard vous voyez on arrivera et mme
emmanuel macron nous parle ensuite de
reprendre notre souveraineté de
reprendre la fabrication notre pouvoir
alors que nous allons dépendre de
vaccins étrangers mais on est où en
réalité qu'est ce que c'est que ce
discours moi ce soir j'ai vu un discours
extrêmement dangereux extrêmement
inquiétant ou derrière
finalement on avait d'ailleurs ces
mouvements de caméra c'est un exercice
de communication très orwélienne mails
macron devant la tour eiffel comme une
seringue géante pour dire que allez vive
la france
on va y aller mais nous n'avons pas de
vaccin france est donc aujourd'hui si
nous rentrons dans cette stratégie
vaccinale
nous allons dépendre de multinationales
qui ne sont pas françaises et qui vont
nous vendre des produits que nous allons
certes embouteillée sur notre territoire
mais que nous ne produisons pas
aujourd'hui je suis désolé on en
bouteille le kaiser qu'on ne produit pas
donc ce soir j'ai vu un président qui
n'est pas du tout un président d'un pays
qui s'appelle la france mais quelqu'un
qui vend ce pays à la découpe et qui
obéit à des lobbys d'intérêts financiers
internationaux extrêmement important et
qui est là pour assurer ce profit
assurer une relance économique soit
disant de 6%
mais j'attends de voir un président des
français on va retrouver dans quelques
instants vous retrouvez un tous les
trois mais non on va faire un petit
détour justement vers l'elysée ce n'est
pas à l'elysée que emmanuel macron fait
ces annonces n'empêche lucas léger a
tout de même suivi cette locution lucas
effectivement ce qui retient l'attention
ce soir ce qui va certainement être le
plus contraignant aujourd'hui pour les
français c'est cette extension du pass
sanitaire que peut-on retenir lucas
oui tout à fait et c'était la huitième à
dresde emmanuel macron aux français
aujourd'hui depuis le début de la crise
ducobu 19 peut-être la plus importante
puisqu'elle est exprime et bien des
projets pour le long terme
il a même parlé évidemment de 2030 même
site et sur la partie économique donc
pour l'extension du pass sanitaires et
bien dès le 21 juillet pour les lieux de
culture et de loisirs à partir de 12 ans
puis ensuite et bien août avec l'aide
bien sûr des parlementaires pour les
restaurants les cafés c'était ce que
redoutaient les personnes qui ne
voulaient pas de cette vaccination
obligatoire je vous propose d'écouter
emmanuel macron dès le 21 juillet le
pass sanitaire sera étendue aux lieux de
loisirs et de culture
concrètement pour tous nos compatriotes
de plus de 12 ans il faudra pour accéder
à un spectacle un parc d'attractions un
concert ou un festival avoir été
vaccinés ou présenter un test négatif
récents ce pass est disponible sur
l'application tout senti qu vide mais
chacun peut utiliser la version papier
remise au moment de la vaccination à
partir du début du mois d'août le pass
sanitaire s'appliquera dans les cafés
les restaurants les centres commerciaux
ainsi que dans les hôpitaux les maisons
de retraite établissements médicaux
sociaux jeux si dans les avions trains
et cars pour les longs trajets là encore
seuls les vaccinés et les personnes
testées négatives pourront accéder à ces
lieux qu'ils soient d'ailleurs clients
usagers ou salariés aujourd'hui seuls
50% des français de plus de 18 ans sont
vaccinés contre locaux vides 19 et le
conseil scientifique estime qu'il
faudrait de 90 à 95% des personnes qui
au moins soit le coût vide soit une
vaccination pour juguler l'épidémie
emmanuel macron a promis qu'il ne
rendrait pas la vaccination obligatoire
au cours de ces dernières allocutions
notamment en novembre puis sur le média
brut en décembre mais les mesures qu'il
s'apprête à prendre sont tellement
incitatives qu'on peut se demander si ça
ne revient pas de faire à oblige
et bien cette vaccination merci le cas
les géants trouvent nos trois invités
maxime sebo éric bouchard et alexis
poulain effectivement avec sylvain on en
parlait à moins de rester enfermé chez
soi il faudra clairement se faire
vacciner si on veut mener une vie
normale y compris chez les mineurs
puisque c'est à partir de plus de 12 ans
la france est clairement précurseur en
la matière beaucoup d'autres pays
européens n'ont pas osé encore franchir
ce pas est ce que ça pose des problèmes
clairement de droit mais bien sûr mais
bien sûr que ça pose un gros problème de
droit par une entente ou les émotifs
vous savez tous les médecins qu'on a
sont les plateaux télé mais combattue
plus jamais dans leurs cabinets médicaux
nous dire la vaccination se fait bien
vaccinés comme d'autres maladies bien
plus grave
et oui les maladies qui tuent réellement
des maladies ou si vous détrompez vous
avez 80 % de mortalité peut-être 10 % de
mortalité
là le kobe de 19 c'est une maladie qui
tue moins de 1% de la population qui
nous concerne en réalité pour les
personnes âgées ou les personnes qui ont
des comorbidités c'est une maladie dont
la vaccination finalement n'est
pratiquement d'intérêt que pour les
personnes qui risque d'en mourir
certains malades c'est à dire les
personnes malades ou des personnes âgées
et là on va obliger des gens sont des
gens qui n'ont aucun risque pour eux
même ou pour autrui à avoir leur accent
si les personnes vulnérables sont
d'accès bien sûr à être vaccinés mais
c'est une attaque est complètement
liberticide
c'est sans précédent dans notre histoire
la liberté d'aller et venir la liberté
d'aller dans des commerces la liberté
culturelle la liberté même ponctuelle
d'être limité à l'obligation de se faire
vacciner mais je ne sais pas si on se
rend compte aujourd'hui des conséquences
pour nos libertés fondamentales que le
président macron a eu ce soir il nous
avait annoncé qu'il ne rendrait pas la
vaccination obligatoire
pourquoi parce qu'il savait très bien
qu'elle n'était pas efficace pour une
partie de la population qui n'a pas être
vaccinés parce que à partir du moment où
les gens qui saturent les hôpitaux les
hôpitaux de son bail à plus de problème
ou jeu
depuis quand vous regardez le variant
delta en grande bretagne vous remarquez
une chose assez simple c'est que certes
le taux d'incidence augmente mais en
fait le taux d'hospitalisation dans mon
coin pas sur une personne vulnérable et
personnes âgées sont vaccinés c'est la
même chose enfin vous aider chez vos
confrères du figaro
des graphiques qui était très très clair
vous avez l'augmentation du taux
d'incidence mais vous aviez pas une
augmentation du taux de statines
hospitalisation et on va voir ça sur le
mois de juillet le mois d'août
donc en fait je suis d'accord avec ce
que disait monsieur klein nous sommes en
fait dans un système 13 ans wadien où
monsieur macron répond à des intérêts
sur la vaccination nous parle de 3e 12
en fait on nous parle sur les prochaines
années d'une date six nations qui sera
récurrente chronique obligatoire chaque
année avec la parole du médecin parce
que les français font confiance à leur
médecin qui je pense est beaucoup
craignent le serment d'hippocrate ces
derniers temps parce que notamment les
ai jamais entendus sur les traitements
alors que ces derniers ont plutôt fait
preuve d'efficacité dans des pays comme
en en inde
donc je me méfie beaucoup des médecins
de plateau en ce moment et on va voir
comme ça sans dresser un système donné
la parole à l'un d'entre eux maxime sebo
justement parce que c'est intéressant
parce que ce que vous nous dites
évidemment de nombreux français
certainement le pense ce soir devant
leur télévision ou la radio
éric bouchard a ses arguments c'est une
maladie qui peut tu très peu notamment
les plus fragiles 1% de la population et
d'une certaine manière ce soir on rend
la vaccination quasi obligatoire pour
les français en tout cas qui ont un tout
petit peu envie de sortir de chez eux qu
est ce que vous nous répondez quels sont
les arguments médicaux sont bien sortis
quelques statistiques qui sont parus
dernièrement l'europe a perdu 300 mille
trois cent mille personnes
il en 2020 c'est à dire qu'il ya donc
trois cent mille décès de plus qui ont
qui sont arrivés ça ne tient pas compte
bien entendu qu'ils ont sorti le plus
élevé puisque on a eu quand même une
arrivée de en immigration
alors concernant la vaccination je pense
que l'eau on oublie hanoune oublié
quelque chose dans les pandémies pour
faire un peu d'histoire des pandémies de
temps en temps il faut regarder toutes
les pandémies elle dure en moyenne deux
ans avec en moyenne trois à quatre
vagues et en général c'est vrai qu'elles
s'arrêtent quasiment tout seul
pourquoi parceque il
le virus ne plus transmettre parce que
les gens meurent je rappelle que la
peste pour donner un petit peu
d'histoire
au moyen-âge et en particulier en
grande-bretagne on arrivait qu'il eut
tellement de morts qu'on avait qui avait
plus suffisamment de vivant pour réussir
à enterrer les morts donc en fait le
problème de fond est assez simple pour
qu'une pandémie s'arrête et qu'un virus
quand tu n'arrêtes inutile puisque c'est
toujours un peu d'inquiétude
il faut qu'on a hâte de le transmettre
c'est quelque chose que je pense que tu
mens pas comprendre qui a pas vrai
d'avoir d'avoir fait sciences po pour le
faire ou même médecine donc comment est
ce qu'on fait on actuellement après la
transmission la transmission elle se
passe demain à rome
elle est le virus certains virus sont
plusieurs langues c'est le cas du delta
donc on va faire simple il faut arrêter
de transmettre pourrait transmettre qui
a les mesures barrières en a tous un peu
marre je lirai il ya le confinement ça
n'a rien de très passionnant et là je
pense que l'appartement qui a vu quand
même une atteinte à nos libertés qui est
autrement plus importante que celle
d'obliger les soignants à se faire
vacciner
qui pour moi après purement éthique
j'imagine j'arrête faire comme ça mais
ça je partage pas votre avis c'est le
point de vue de beaucoup de médecins de
mes confrères il ya un premier clip vous
avez vous rigolez ça change pas le
problème on admettre qu'il ya des choses
qui doivent être faites par les
professionnels de santé au sens large
c'est quelque chose de normal
après je dirais concernant la classe
sanitaires j'ai un avis mitigé de ce que
je leur donne et je reconnais que je
suis perplexe sur le moniteur à cette
heure là j'ai pas encore excusez moi
j'essaie de parler vous prie le sait
parler je sais que nous avions quand il
a beaucoup de bêtises tu ferais qui vend
tous assez bavard d'entre eux melvin mal
à la voilà on a le sentiment de alexis
poule a en tout cas
une chose qui va vous faire sourire de
mais leur trace d'ironie qu 17000 rendez
vous pris toutes les minutes sur notre
solide depuis la locution d' emmanuel
macron ça donc c'est fonctionner mais
évidemment que ça fonctionne l'idée
c'est de refourguer tout ce qu'il reste
de vaccins en disant à l'aise ici vous
pouvez si vous hésitez n'hésitez pas il
faut le faire et puis vous aurez ensuite
l'ouverture de la 3ème de la 4e et puis
de l'est que vous voulez et puis il faut
faire confiance à ce vaccin après tout
puisqu'il fonctionne effectivement en
terme d'après de de protection face à
des formes graves
ça marche mais très peu de gens encore
une fois développent des formes graves
et puis après c'est surtout sur la la
contagion 12 fois moins de contagion si
vous êtes vacciné donc c'est en ça que
ce vaccin est une chance pour l'économie
pour la relance de l'économie
mais quand le pass sanitaire va être mis
en place attention moi j'aurai une
question à la personne qui me demandera
mon pass sanitaire je demanderai
simplement si les vaccinés et de me
montrer également son pass sanitaire
parce que c'est quoi ce bordel
excusez moi du terme on est en train de
faire que des restaurateurs des gens qui
sont des commerçants vont devenir des
capots vont devenir des gens qui vous
vous demandez si vous avez le droit de
rentrer chez eux mais on est où si ces
gens-là accepte ce monde là alors ils
seront prêts à accepter le pire après ça
parce que là on est souvent une question
très simple je veux bien qu'on en ait
marre du masque je veux bien qu'on ait
masque de marc du du gel etc
mais quand on aura des vaccins qui
maistrienne on en aura peut-être marre
aussi finalement de se dire mais
attendez je n'avais pas signé pour ça et
on vous dira oui mais vous savez le coc
vite ça évolue on en est à l'oméga
maintenant alors vous comprenez on a
fait toutes les lettres de l'alphabet
grec va passer maintenant sur des
symboles égyptien donc comprenez qu'il
faut continuer un moment ça suffit en
fait de lever les uns contre les autres
de faire que les non vaccinés sont les
ennemis des vaccinés de fer que certains
n'auraient pas le droit
les mêmes droits que d'autres citoyens
parce qu'ils ont choisi finalement de ne
pas prendre un produit qui n'a pas
encore fait toutes ses preuves alors
certains les études le disent des études
qui sont encore une fois financé par
ceux là qui vendent ces vaccins moi je
suis pas anti vaccins je pense que c'est
une avancée phénoménale sur ce qu vide
la rapidité de ses
ces roms la façon tout ça a été géré me
pose question et devrait poser question
à tout le monde et la violence avec
lesquels ceux qui veulent vacciner à
tout prix tout le monde et met
maintenant à la vindicte populaire des
non vaccinés devrait aussi nous poser
question et puis ensuite ce modèle de
société ou des restaurateurs ou des
commerçants devraient redevenir des
policiers des capots devrait aussi nous
poser question je suis désolé ce n'est
plus la démocratie ce n'est plus une
société libérale
nous sommes en train de rentrer dans un
modèle à la chinoise de citoyenneté
avéré si l'état vous a dit de faire ça
et que vous l'avez fait alors vous avez
tous les droits
si vous avez ou contraire ne pas vous
n'avez pas accepter finalement ce qu'a
dit l'état alors vous êtes un mauvais
citoyen ou honte à vous vous n'aurez
droit à rien et si les français
acceptent ça alors je crois que le
xxième siècle sera très compliqué en
france et en europe
maxime thibeault à vous qui voilà qui
est vent debout contre ces pass
sanitaires quand on ferme des
restaurants sur des lieux de vacances
parce qu'il ya des clusters ça arrive
dans ce moment encore sein par exemple
qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on
fait dans ces cas là on ne ferme pas du
tout les restaurants ou alors
effectivement les personnes qui se sont
vaccinés pâtissent de ces clusters
peut-être de la part de gens non vacciné
je me pose la question parce que c'est
aussi un argument qu'on entend de la
part des gens qui sont plutôt pro
vaccination donc c'est bien d'avoir les
deux sons de cloche mais j'ai eu la
preuve d'une contamination est donc le
store dans des restaurants devant le
conseil d'état le gouvernement n'a
jamais été capable d'en apporter la
preuve
moi je ne lis que les conclusions qui
sont faits par les conseillers n'est pas
dans les différentes mesures dans les
différentes ordonnances suites r d saisi
en référé on se rend compte qu'on soit
tous sur le conditionnel en permanence
et principe de précaution car elle
voulait jamais arrivé on n'est jamais
arrivé à démontrer ou circulaires
réellement le virus
à part dire c'est dans les lieux clos ça
s'arrête là mais on n'a jamais pu le
démontrer
moi je ne vois qu'une seule chose je
suis un peu déçu on faisait un peu droit
comparé au niveau international on a été
l'un des rares pays en europe à avoir un
coup reçu aussi longtemps à avoir un
confinement si longtemps avoir une
fermeture des restaurants des
une culture aussi longtemps on est l'un
des premiers pays au monde à avoir
l'obligation vaccinale pour l'ensemble
des français
art de facto juste en automne mais de
droits à partir du mois d'octobre les
mois d'octobre novembre donc
donc on n'est plus un pays libéral la
personne qui me dit aujourd'hui je c'est
un pays libéral elle ne sait pas ce
qu'est un état libéral et la sécurité
n'est pas la première des libertés
l'ordre public il n'intervient il doit
être finalement on doit mettre fin au
trouble à l'ordre public
lorsqu'il s'avère qu'il les dise des
mesures qui ont fait la preuve qu'elles
sont efficaces pour établir cet ordre
public
face à cet ordre sanitaires on se rend
compte que la vaccination ne s'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga
face à ce problème sanitaire il faut
lutter conte qu'elle comorbidités il
faut avoir en tête des solutions via les
traitements il faut réfléchir à réouvrir
des places d'hospitalisation
il faut penser à la vaccination des
personnes vulnérables et des personnes
âgées et faire preuve de pédagogie vers
ces personnes parce que c'est là qu'on
voit qu'il ya le plus haut taux de
mortalité mais obligé l'ensemble de la
population française à se faire vacciner
alors que cela n'a aucune efficacité et
en plus monter les français les uns
contre les autres du politique qui
relève davantage du machiavélisme que de
la politique sanitaire
éric bouchard le mot de la fin pour vous
ce pass sanitaire est ce qu'il est
vraiment efficace on se rappelle que ces
fameux supporters écossais sont revenus
avec le co vide alors même que qu'ils
avaient un passani terre qu'ils ont
présentée avant de rentrer dans ce stade
de l'euro est ce que c'est vraiment ce
qu'il fallait faire il ya deux sujets
deux points de vue là-dessus je pense
que d'abord il va difficilement faisable
je pense que les deux interlocuteurs à
expliquer les problèmes je vois pas un
restaurateur demandé de personnalités a
systématiquement ça va être compliqué
même si dans la théorie on peut l'avoir
avec soi la vaccination soit
éventuellement avec un test pcr négatif
néanmoins d'autres se passer ni t elle
existe déjà
si vous voulez aller en grèce
actuellement vous n'êtes pas sanitaires
ils ont inauguré à maintenant quelque
chose qui s'appelle le ps
f je pense que je ne sais plus très bien
pop correspondance et acronymes où
j'étais obligé d'envoyer votre
certificat de vaccination par l'état
grec pourrait donc vous remplissez tout
ça il vous autorise à venir donc on est
déjà dans cette problématique là et donc
la liberté elle est déjà très limité
elle se limitait là dessus c'est vrai
que ce serait un peu comme bouldin pas
trop que ma liberté soit limité à la
matière mais je pense que peu savent pas
sanitaires sinon on a droit de ne pas
être d'accord
j'ai entendu beaucoup de bêtises que
j'ai entendu des choses qui sortent
aussi et donc je pense qu'une
premièrement en force demandé à des
restaurateurs ou d'autres de vérifier ça
me paraît impossible techniquement je
sais pas comment ça va être possible
donc je pense qu'ils vont faire
attention à mesure que l'on que l'on
prend moi je reste sur la seule mesure
qui me paraît être la plus judicieuse
actuellement éthique non la plus
cohérente celle à l'obligation pour les
professionnels de santé
je reste dessus je suis très clair après
il y avait les lui je crois qu'il y
avait il y avait donc le pcr payant on
en a pas trop parlé j'ai pas non plus à
la vie spéciale je dirais que c'est
peut-être pas nécessairement plus leur
une et la sécurité sociale et dans sa
tombe tous les cinq minutes en la
matière pour terminer on a au moins un
point de vue qui est commun avec celles
de nos deux autres interlocuteurs
beaucoup d'interrogations sur le pass
sanitaires et un point de vue très
différents
je pense que les professions de santé
doivent se faire vacciner a rayé le mot
de la fin va aussi un lieu consacré à à
d'autres annonces à au combien
importante qui vont peut-être
certainement modifier la rentrée 1
puisque emmanuel macron est revenu sur
la nécessité de plusieurs réformes dont
celle de l'assurance chômage à partir du
1er octobre la réforme des retraites fin
des régimes spéciaux recul de l'âge
légal de la retraite qui sera nécessaire
pas avant que l'épidémie soit sous
contrôle
un petit mot terrebonne pour terminer
alexis poulain sur ac annonce pour le
moins explosif dans les mois qui
viennent oui on voit bien qu'on est
typiquement dans la stratégie du choc un
telle qu'elle a été expliqué on profite
d'une crise pour en faire une
opportunité et faire passer des mesures
qui ne seraient jamais passés en temps
normal et emmanuel macron très
clairement a attendu la fin de son
allocution pour
l'air de rien dire que finalement oui il
fera ses mesures si la crise sanitaire
est jugulée bien entendu et qu' il
faudra de toute façon les faire qu'il
n'y a pas d'autre choix
il a maintenant quelques mois devant lui
pour finir ce qu'il a commencé
c'est-à-dire vendre à la découpe achevé
le système social français alors même
qu'il se défend de d'être là pour le
protéger pour le pérenniser
c'est scandaleux ça fait partie
également de cette manipulation
permanente qui a été la marque de ce
quinquennat de la violence aussi qui a
été la marque de ce quinquennat
ce soir ce discours moi m'a effrayée
j'espère qu'il a effrayé de nombreux
français parce que ce qui se profile si
jamais mal mâcon devait être réélu
et bien c'est tout sauf une démocratie
libérale comme maxime thibault vient de
le dire et je crois que nous devons être
vigilants parce que les contre-pouvoirs
sont faibles aujourd'hui en france et
parce que le débat démocratique n'existe
pas quand il dit que nous avons
collectivement fait des choix non il a
choisi seul lors des conseils de défense
les confinements ou non maintenant il a
choisi seul lors du conseil de défense
de ce matin la vaccination quasiment
obligatoire avec le pass annie terre
partout ce n'est pas démocratique
le conseil d'état malheureusement elle
est bien seul tout comme le conseil
constitionnel pour essayer de limiter
les dégâts
mais en réalité le peuple et en dehors
de l'équation le peuple français lui
n'est jamais consulté sur ces grands
orientations qui vont vous emmener très
loin des rives de la démocratie libérale
merci en tout cas tous les 3 maxime
thiébaut éric bouchard alexis à poulain
merci d'avoir débriefer donc cette
allocution d' emmanuel macron ce soir